healing is i've found to be very hard  there's a lot of pain crying confusion i  wonder if we have to go through the fire  to come out the other side and so you're  talking about writing a book to help  people  become  the one in their relationship you had to  go through your own fire to do that and  i and i really wonder are there any  shortcuts  is there anywhere that we can  heal grow and evolve  without having to go through the fire  growth comes through challenge and and  that's why relationships are our  greatest spiritual growth container but  they're also the hardest sometimes it  really is just going to be hard and  painful and stinky embracing that is  part of the medicine it's not a bad  thing even though it feels uncomfortable  to get messy to lay it all out on the  table it's actually a gift because we're  sort of de-armoring in those moments and  we're really letting what's true come  through and we're also letting the  people closest to us see us